let's bring in Terry Pluto sports
columnist for the Cleveland Plain Dealer
he's been around a long time he's
watched the good the bad and the ugly
and in the city of Cleveland certainly
with the Cavaliers and he joins us now
local reaction for John Beilein is is
what Terry really upbeat I think we
stands heard of him they probably were
fearful yeah you're good I mean
seriously you're Nate tivitz or Jody
Fernandez or all these guys I mean heck
I basketball in this and I'm like
searching the internet on these people
that are interviewing you know what I
mean Wes Unseld jr. so I think in also
let's face it he's in the big ten you're
in big ten country here they watched a
b-line beat Ohio State a whole lot so
well hey why not yeah I'm there with you
two I read your column with you know
that it might work
I you know it's tricky with the Cavs and
ownership there and they gonna give him
that the amount of time that it would
take for him and usually with a coach in
college we wait for his first you know
true recruiting class to filter through
I don't know does he get that I know
he's got a five-year deal but how
patient are they in Cleveland alright
Dan let's put it this way I just saw a
survey done by a guy named Kip right in
the last twenty years he went through
all the NBA coaches the average lifespan
is two and a half seasons okay
furthermore there have been three teams
in the last twenty years I've had 12
coaches and the Cavs are not one of them
beef at 11 so okay
you sign for five and if he gets three
you're probably doing what home and I
think that in this case you know this is
a Dan Gilbert choice to big-time and
he's a lot more committed to him than he
would be you know some of these other
guys you know Gilbert's a Detroit guy
he's a college basketball fan he tried a
higher Tom Izzo back in 2010 so I do
think in that sense at least he had a
few years but none of these guys get
very much time well the Cavs you know
you've been in the lottery here and
you've won four times in the last 16
years I think we feel like it's a
foregone conclusion
or the media once I on to end up in New
York but you know if you're Cleveland
you guys are probably pretty confident
about tonight right I mean you got Nick
Gilbert you know this is I mean that is
a cool story you know Nick I think it's
had five or six brain surgeries he's
dealt with all those tumors and
everything dan Gilbert son they'll be
there was bowtie and hey go for it you
know if they end up in the top three
suddenly you've got a really good
employer coming this way and I think you
the idea that the cows were thinking too
and I wrote about this economist now
posted is they got off of suddenly we
got to have a young coach for a young
team and what about a guys and very
successful coaching young guys and they
also like to be line that most of his
good players I mean these are not blue
chipper these are not McDonald's
all-americans and he really did get them
to play together and all that and you
know I kind of asked myself what I'd
rather have John Beilein drawing up
place at the end of a game or frankly an
assistant I never heard of Kevin love's
future there is what I think actually
it's fairly strong unless they get a
really big deal for him hmm what the
here's why they want to have Kevin Love
and maybe like Matthew Dellavedova and
some of the a couple other lighting or
some of these other guys just a couple
not a lot but a few to help usher them
with these young people that they're
going to be drafting or that they have
right now Collin Sexton said he Osmond
and furthermore to support the coach
that's what they want they don't want to
just go you know total cool process all
young guys let's lose every single game
they're at that point they that's what
they're really looking at you know and
lovest wanted to stay I heard again for
somebody Nova well he still doesn't want
to be traded yeah interesting yeah but I
think because the Cavs are supported him
remember through the panic attacks man
and then the injury and it's funny that
they with the first call the Cavs made
after LeBron left was to Kevin Love he's
on the phone with them saying you know
let's stay and if you want to work an
extension I'm open to it it was it's
fascinating to watch what's evolved with
him you know unfortunately you got to
get him on the court here's an
interesting thing in the last
he had foot surgery then he came back he
poised 16 games after that where he
played at least 15 minutes
they went 7 and 9 with him ok
we're talking to change I'm not
predicting yeah I'm not wasting any
banners or anything here but you know
Terry Pluto the sports columnist for the
Cleveland Plain Dealer I'm curious from
afar looking at what's happening with
the Lakers with LeBron mm-hmm your
thoughts oh boy this is the first time
for LeBron made a move where he didn't
think it out by that be think about you
went to Miami you know they put together
they you team you know to make sure that
worked and it's kind of how you would do
it you know I don't mean told version
there but these guys recruit their
players would go on when he came to
Cleveland he had a meeting with Dan
Gilbert I wrote about this and I booked
the comeback and that how they sat there
and they laid out how they could get
Kevin Love how much money they were
going to have in a salary cap other
moves they could make they talked about
you know Mike Miller all kinds of guys
there that was all set before he even
came to Cleveland so I don't know what
he set up before he went to the Lakers
what to get
raesha I mean raison rondo Michael
Beasley what were they doing I don't
know I've been fake and I agree I don't
know I don't think it was thought out
other than I'm going to Los Angeles and
I mean there's good and I want to be in
the movies I don't know I mean I don't
mean that and look I've first
interviewed LeBron he's 15 and you've
one thing you look this guy is very
calculating and even here how he built
and all the stuff you hear about what
the LeBron James Foundation and those
things anytime they had a little hiccup
with that they would fix it in the
charity work you said in Northeast Ohio
in his school and then that stuff's not
real then it's big-time that's why we're
so hot about this and now this whole
tyronn lue thing you're bringing a man
you don't want to hire them you know
Tyler moon was the guy sitting next to
David Blatt knowing that if David Blatt
failed he'd get the job why just ironic
Jason Gibson and aren't the Cavs still
paying tyronn lue oh yeah man the Cavs
like to pay a lot of people not to coach
but I was also one
during this though Terry and I don't
know if you looked at this and maybe I
read into things too much but I looked
at they were gonna bring in tyloo they
wanted him for three years LeBron has
three years left on his contract are the
Lakers saying that they believe that
LeBron will be done in three years with
them and therefore that's the only
reason why if LeBron had five years left
on his deal just tyloo get five years I
don't know I mean they just I don't know
what they're doing I mean you know what
frank vogel for three years and and you
want Jason Kidd we'll just hire Jason
Kidd yeah I'm serious
I mean I I don't get it and I was
talking to some other executives and
they're kind of some of the things I'm
telling you with what they were telling
me it's like well if you want Jason Kidd
hire Jason Kidd you can't just turn
around when a guy is to actually tie has
two more years on his contract and then
say we'll just give you an extra year
and even it's just a match up with
LeBron or whatever or if you don't
believe tyloo is ready to coach why are
you talking to him because you know the
big issue here
people forget Ty Lee was sick LeBron's
last year by that I mean he missed 10
games with a variety of physical
problems and he wasn't feeling all that
great even when this last season opened
he was the only better than year before
but there's some you know there's some
issues there too so but I don't know if
that and I don't know what entered into
anything with the Lakers so in the
bronze thing I don't know why magic
laughs I didn't hear a thing come I mean
we'll talk to him yeah that was odd too
now you don't even reach out to him yeah
let me find out what's going on so it's
just you know what's put it this way it
will be interesting to see if they could
bail out and they get Anthony Davis or
whoever they get in the minutes really I
mean the other thing that's funny from
the Cleveland perspective is you know
Kyrie Irving walks in with two years
left to go on his contract
and says I want to be the focal point of
a team I want to be out of here in fact
if you don't trade me I'm going to have
knee surgery right now then he goes to
the Celtics and finds out he can't beat
LeBron and frankly messed up all that
good stuff that Brad Stevens had going
there because Cleveland fans got a very
good look at the Celtics at how
and unselfish they were no different
playoff series you know without Kyrie
Kyrie is very gifted and really strange
and this is just you know I go back and
think about he got that you know the
uncle drool thing real early in his
career and all-star game MVP and that
but frankly when they were here with him
for three years they didn't make the
playoffs you know granted the roster
kept getting better but it wasn't like
they were you just felt like he could
just carry them I mean it it happened
123 showed up I'll leave you with his
how big is Baker Mayfield in Cleveland
do you think you should have a
super-sized statue or just like a normal
just a normal just just a life-size
statue I think it's huge into Baker's
credit I mean he's played into you know
the dog pound the underground the
underdog notion you know and post
pictures of he's at the you know the
make-a-wish thing or he's he's really
done a good job of you know tapping into
how Cleveland fans see each other and
they're so desperate to win and in those
last eight games you know they were five
and three wasn't that just that they had
a top I think as a seventh ranked
offense in the NFL with that it's going
to be fun I worry I think it still comes
down to two kitchens can can he handle
all of this because that's a big jump
from where he was to now being a head
coach and you got a lot of personalities
in there on board with that and you're
also asking a lot out of your rookie
quarterback now so much on the field but
to handle old Oh Beckham Jarvis Landry
etc hmm but I'll say this John Dorsey
the talent he's infused in here and you
know I like Nick's job lost in the
background that guy is a heck of a
running back he really is and you know
they've been adding defensive players my
view is always like you got to beat the
Steelers and when your division have a
winning record first before you talk
about this other stuff but at least this
is the first year I think you know they
could probably could beat the Steelers
and they got a chance to really good
chance to win the division
huh got to believe right hey why not I
mean it's either that or I VI by the way
this is also the year Derek D Anderson
retired and he that's the last time he
had a winning record just like flipped
on the one the other day Derek Anderson
retired of course I think a lot of us
thought he had years ago but but that
wasn't he was 10 and 6 yeah yeah
a long long time ago hey I like all
about the Halley's Comet season it sort
of showed up I don't know where and then
disappear Terry good to talk to you
again thank you good luck tonight
welcome down
all right that's Terry Pluto Terry a
longtime NBA guide sports columnist for
the Cleveland Plain Dealer for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]